a longtime observer of United States
soccer joining us here on the Rich Eisen
show before I get to the NFL stuff Jason
I'll give you the floor what what what
is wrong with US soccer on the men's
side obviously I think it's broken from
the highest reaches of its bureaucracy
where certain people seem to assume they
had jobs for life and it was their
fiefdom and they could do as they wish
all the way down to the grassroots level
where despite proclamations that soccers
for everyone and and soccer you know is
a great unifier the the soccer culture
in America is is decidedly divided and
there's been forever really in this
country a inability to identify and
develop talent that can compete at an
elite level at a truly world-class level
and the dirty little secret is you don't
have to do that to get by in in in
CONCACAF except now they can't even
finish fourth in a 16 table I mean
there's a lot that has to happen first
of all MLS they finally started these
developmental academies but all they
really do is take the best players from
the FC delle cose and the pipelines and
these youth these established suburban
youth teams that are already developing
the place and then they get them onto
their team and and whatever but why
don't you put your youth academy in
Liberty City why don't you put your
youth academy in the southside of
Chicago
why don't you put your youth academy in
Patterson Park where I grew up in
Baltimore why don't you put a youth
academy in Southie
I mean why don't you running clinics for
under 8 kids under 6 kids why aren't you
showing them that it's not just football
and baseball I could get you a
scholarship I could get you
international fame Christian polo sticks
from hershey sell the story of christian
bowling at the grassroot level to kids
who might take soccer and something
where if I apply my ambitions it will
open up the world to me and not as
something I do if we can't get the field
for football or baseball this week you
need to take the money out of the sport
the college system the NCAA either has
to do something where a kid like Jordan
Morris who's clearly too good for
Stanford but he doesn't want to go
abroad to Germany well let me start
playing for the Seattle Sounders have to
seize it or something the idea that our
best 18-year olds are going
play soccer three months out of the year
while in any other country they'd
already be in a competitive environment
in a real Academy playing against men 11
months out of the season you can't close
that gap and then thirdly MLS does the
country no service when it takes when it
says to a Michael Bradley at age 26 or
28 we know you have to compete every
single day to keep your spot at AS Roma
and stay in the matchday squad and then
stay in the reserve team if you're not
doing well or we're gonna ship you out
to the middle of nowhere somewhere a
level below in another league because
you can't hack it here well no MLS let's
give him a soft landing spot we're not
the wait for that point let's pay him
more than he's worth now let's let him
pick the team he wants to go to and then
he knows he's in the first 11 every time
for club and country just by showing up
you take the competition out there's no
relegation in MLS so most of the games
don't matter and if you brought over as
a protected player a designated player
and they're paying you all that money
Jozy Altidore Michael Bradley Clint
Dempsey Tim Howard you're gonna play
you're gonna play whenever you want to
play as long as you feel like it and the
coach probably is gonna hold you
accountable on national team two and
because you're making money for MLS
you're gonna play that so in other words
this design needs to be broken so that
that that that so there's no answer I
mean what you just said was as as
intelligent and as cogent a an analysis
as well as a road map who's gonna do
that who's gonna do that would have to
happen now it's an EO galati and dance
plan and the people who have been the
puppet master for years need to get the
hell out of soccer house in Chicago they
need to bring in tab Ramos and then the
other youth coach under 17 under 20 they
need to bring in still nice you need to
bring in ambev because I guess great
Budweiser's and really in America
they're owned by hands their five
biggest sponsors a Gatorade and they
need to chart the blueprint to actually
make soccer the sport of the urban part
of the back alley oh the plot of grass
in the middle of nowhere because if they
don't do that this cycle will not change
and at the high end they have to
understand that you know perhaps making
MLS sort of the new nouveau NASL where
if it's not going great for you in
Europe instead of plying your trade at
the highest level come here and make
money to do that that can exist either
so
it's not doing it at the bottom and the
guys on the top are being rewarded for
coming home from Europe years before
they should I mean the fact that Jordan
isn't in Germany working his butt off in
the Bundesliga but knows I'll just go to
Seattle and the money will be pretty
good and I'm straight I'll still be on
the national team Jurgen Klinsmann
brought up a lot of uncomfortable truths
Jurgen Klinsmann had a lot of flaws
I would prefer Jurgen Klinsmann as a
technical director and not my manager
but the problem was he shook them to
their core and and then one more thing I
want to say because I have this this
bully pit here for Jason the borderline
jingoism that went on in this Federation
the idea that German nationals who were
born in Germany but have American
parents they don't like the crust as
much as us and when they threw Klinsmann
out and you had Tim Howard making
comments like that and Abby Wambach and
Sunil Gulati and other seemingly
condoning itches I don't remember those
people being suspended and the idea was
like oh it's because Fabian Johnson
isn't a real American and Timmy
Chandler's not a real American John
Anthony Brooks isn't a real American so
they don't want it as bad none of them
are on the pitch for that disgrace last
night if anything they should have gone
with more dual nationals because the fat
cats who go to MLS and don't play in the
Bundesliga and don't play and even the
English Championship or the English
Premiership there are the ones who got
it easy there are the ones who let the
country down
Jason Locke and four of CBS sports here
on the Rich Eisen show let's turn the
page here for a few minutes we have left
to American football if we can did you
have dinner with Colin Kaepernick last
night have dinner with him but I did
hang out with him for close to three
hours in New York on Saturday so let's
hit the storylines that we hear about
him do you want to play football badly
okay either way is he in football shape
he looked it to me and from some videos
and pictures I've seen and talking to
his trainer and looking at his daily
regimen which includes an uber from New
York City to a remote location in Jersey
at 4:00 a.m. every day so he can get his
work in before that part gets crowded so
he can throw a couple hundred balls and
then come back to the city and then work
out for a couple of hours and go up town
to Harlem and mentor kids and
after-school programs he looked pretty
good to me would he take a second
third-string dig in the innocent just
wants a workout right he told me like I
understand if I'm this distraction and
if they don't want to bring me
they're building on a Tuesday like
everybody else I'll get myself to a high
school field nearby just let an
evaluator tell me I can't compete with
TJ Yates and Brandon Weeden and these
guys who teams now have to go to in a
dire straight and if I and if they see
me as a football player then I would
hope to get the opportunity to go in
front of an owner and present myself and
make him comfortable with me and then I
just want to play football it's just
about he can't fill out the job
application right you want to go work at
j.crew you walk working you fill an
application you wanna get a job in the
NFL this time of year you got to get a
workout on a Tuesday no one will give
him that opportunity the Tennessee
Titans didn't even entertain it but if
prior to making a sale at a j.crew the
national anthem had to be played and you
set for it the Jake crew folks might
fire you Jason so my question is is what
what what what would be what would be
his figurative stance should he get the
job again I think that would have to be
discussed with an owner I mean and he
gets that he gets that he's not you know
going to be the same case as everybody
else he's hoping that by keeping his
head down by focusing on his two
vocations football and those advocating
for those who maybe don't have a voice
or who don't have the same opportunities
as everybody else that at some point the
need for football will allow him to be
evaluated as a football player and if he
passes that test then he's you know he
would love to talk to owners he would
love to get an opportunity one-on-one to
sort of share where he is and where he's
going and you know to work with them but
I guess the assumption has been the
football has to come first and and to
this point he's you know he talked to
John Schneider he talked to Pete Carroll
he's talked to John Harbaugh but that's
been the expensive a couple more minutes
here left with Jason lock and for him
and obviously though the conversation
it's not even a conversation the the
argument has no longer been set as to
what Colin Kaepernick was trying to draw
attention to it's essentially now been
categorized by the president as you
stand for the flag and if you don't you
are against it and you're against all of
us who are patriots and you're not and
you're sob etc so the league is having a
meeting next week with
ownership it has something been decided
already what is what is going on behind
the scenes here no I mean there's
several camps here and obviously this
has become such a divisive issue and
people are framing it and reframing it
to sort of meet their needs but the
bottom line is the NFL is a business and
you know if a president quote-unquote
only has 36 or 38 percent of the country
behind him plus another group of people
who maybe don't believe with him
politically but who just won't football
to be their escape on Sunday now that's
a pretty that's enough people to make
you worried about attendance and ratings
and sponsorships so there's some people
who are with Trump and just saying
everybody should stand it shouldn't be
an issue there's some owners who feel
like their players should have the right
to do that
but sort of at what cost there's some
who aren't sure and there's the league
who's trying to bridge this gap by
creating this ongoing conversation with
players to say we will invest assets
time money ourselves into your outreach
in community specific grassroots efforts
but you're Malcolm Jenkins and trying
the criminal justice reform or going to
Capitol Hill or riding with police
officers or helping doing community
policing we're going to support all that
but sort of the rub would be we'd like
for this 90 seconds on Sundays not to be
a point of sort of demonstration or
protest I don't know how you get uniform
uniformity I can bear no no unity on
that among that many players right and
and does it come as some would want to
do the carrot and there's some others
who just want to do the stick and they
want to have a vote and come out of this
meeting saying you either stand or we're
telling you right now we're going to
find you know find you suspend you sit
you or whatever I can't tell you what
the outcome will be my suspicion from
the people I've talked to is it's
somewhere in the middle and more aligned
along the lines of we're going to
reinforce the idea that we can do these
things that are in the game-day manual
we really don't want to do them and
we're going to give you concrete things
that we're going to do in the community
for you and we're going to hope this
thing sorts itself out what about in one
minutes ago what about doing what the
NBA does allow the guys to wear whatever
they want to wear make whatever
statements they want to make before the
game and I
stand that that what they're currently
doing right now does not end remotely
equate to what is a fashion statement
but what about that the and and and and
some sort of compromise in the middle
here as opposed to just some Fiat that
might get the players outraged and thus
a lot of fans right I don't think it's
gonna come down and in that extreme
manner but I mean we've seen what
they're doing now with you know easing
what you're going to be able to put on
your sneakers and stuff like that that's
a conversation that people at Park
Avenue are open to having I guess I just
don't know that they're gonna come out
of that meeting was sort of a concrete
policy I suspect it reads more like a
mission statement that that still does
have some open-ended parts to it
Jason great chat on both football
international and domestic
thanks Matt Jason locking for CBS sports
insider Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you like some of
that get some more of that on the Rich
Eisen show app follow all the
information you see right here on the
Rich Eisen show